like hey listen um every now that i'm  gonna be naked and when i am do whatever  you want that's being a real man yeah  that's a real man yeah yeah  until it turns on you  what really happens is she'll come  around and bone you in the butt that's  not what i was thinking about man my  asshole's all loose thank you don't be  naked you can see me around just put  something in my ass  that's why i don't like she goes hey  come here and i'm like  she pulls my hips over and she goes turn  around i'm like nah yo i'm just not  trying to go to my room yeah yeah yeah  what you need to do is be one step ahead  of her tries to poke you on the butthole  yeah you already have a sharpie right  there a sharpie yeah so when she touches  your butt what the [ __ ] what's all this  ink oh  but instead of a sharpie why not put  melted chocolate oh and then it's just a  snack out of my ass crack dude